[Musica]
ma voglio un applauso gelese più
international rientro non posso entrare
in zona rossa così
adesso
grazie grazie grazie
grazie alla vostra spontaneità mi
commuove grazie popolo di gela
buonasera buonasera a tutti
bentrovati io sono peppe tringali
batterista percussionista
se vi serve un idraulico non c'è
problema vengono a casa ha trovato
vicino sono anche
docente di percussioni presso il liceo
musicale turrisi colonna di catania ma
stasera in realtà ecco lo strumento del
potere vi parlerò in realtà di una
formula matematica di mia invenzione
che già ridono non c'è rispetto che
applicata alla fisica quantistica qui è
tutto abbastanza chiaro genererà un
algoritmo che vi farà fare una carbonara
buonissima
scusate scusate
ecco ecco la carbonara mi sono giocato
le slide
perfetto non va più via la carbonara
bene comunque poi vi lascio il link qua
sotto della carbonara perché lassù fare
veramente veramente bene allora
perché sono qua boh non lo so non lo so
in realtà
credo che la mia vita sia stata
condizionata proprio già dai suoni che
io in qualche maniera sentivo nella
pancia della mamma tra la cisti cella e
il pancreas perché papà catanese quindi
capite bene con i suoni
[Applauso]
questo è già i lo sentivo dalla pancia
si sente così lo ricordo la mamma più
come dire più algida più più ragusana
più da quando gioco arabi quindi questo
è e io invece gelese diciamo certo quasi
autoctono
quindi tutti questi suoni hanno generato
in me proprio l'essere autoctono aim e
gilles
incaricato ecco suggerimento inc arcade
per la traduzione del telex è in realtà
io scopro qui la mia passione per la
musica la scopro e accendo il il fuoco
da gela come la scopro casualmente il
mio amico gianni bassista oggi
professionista e multi talento insomma
talento multiforme tutto quello che fa
insomma andiamo a trovare lui e la sua
famiglia in campagna
dove gianni io vedevo tutti quanti a
destra che erano lì che stavano
mangiando che stavano bevendo che
stavano si divertivano un sacco gianni
non c'è gianni e lì a tre o quattrocento
metri un puntino seduto su una sedia
che sta ascoltando già della musica
importante della musica di livello
superiore di qualità artistica eccelsa
sta ascoltando it's final countdown
degli europe e voglio dire eh già
insomma un percorso importante stiamo
parlando dell 87 88 circa 12 anni
ma muove le mani all'impazzata io penso
a un disturbo psico motorio e importante
mi avvicino a lui e dopo trentadue
secondi anche io ero con il disturbo
psico motorio questo disturbo psico
motorio durerà altri insomma 34 anni ne
aveva 12 più 34 28 fantastico li porto
bene lo so però così la matematica è
insomma è un'opinione cominciò a
frequentare un oratorio che chiamarlo
oratorio è assolutamente riduttivo
condotto da don angelo con sacerdote
assolutamente visionario parlo del cesma
voglio citarlo dove faccio l'esperienza
la stessa esperienza qui a gela che fa
un
ragazzo a new york nelle chiese gospel
nelle accademie dello spettacolo perché
noi suoniamo un musical
la tradizione americana
della tradizione italiana
anche la bella tradizione siciliana
ma tutto aveva un senso una direzione
non era dico l'arte non era un'entità
fine a se stessa puramente estetica era
un mezzo una
un mezzo in quel caso di
comunicazione di educazione
questo lo prendo e lo porto con me nella
nella mia esperienza qui a gela con i
musicisti che mi hanno insegnato che mi
hanno fatto appassionare che poi sono
diventati amici fraterni e colleghi la
porto con me negli studi successivi e
nell'esperienza poi di musicista
professionista è di docente durante
lockdown chiaramente il momento
riflessivo e forzato un po per tutti
mi chiedo realmente quali fossero questi
elementi che partendo da questo assunto
mi avessero consentito di continuare la
professione di musicista e di docente
con questa curiosità crescente con
questa passione ovviamente non esente
tutto da da errori ea loro generato il
mio di algoritmo quello quello secondo
me importante per me e il mio algoritmo
è formato da questi tre elementi
apparentemente banali perché noi abbiamo
un mondo che ci vuole originali e
secondo me invece tornare al senso delle
cose alla al significato delle cose
esattamente come quel senso di cui
parlavo prima e quasi fondamentale
la generosità il batterista
il ruolo del batterista ha in sé la
generosità la generosità di lasciare
agli altri il ruolo di solisti
la generosità nel contenere la propria
energia e quella dello strumento che ha
chiaramente una grande energia dinamica
per adeguarsi al volume necessario il
docente generoso e il docente che educa
all'errore della polvere
all'accettazione della della sconfitta
perché solo attraverso la caduta del
sacrificio i ragazzi hanno quella
trasformazione
anno riescono ad arrivare a quella
consapevolezza secondo cui
il raggiungimento degli obblighi quali
cui obiettivo è possibile affinando
l'unico vero talento che non è la
predisposizione musicale quella aiuta ma
l'unico vero grande talento e la forza
di volontà
essere musicisti onesti significa
accogliere tutte le critiche quelle
belle quelle brutte soprattutto sono
quelle brutte insomma che bisogna
accogliere perché questo dice andare in
profondità di far spostare
i tuoi limiti
e avere anche la libertà di osare
insomma di dire le cose perché il
politically correct
a volte anzi non a volte blocca
la l'evoluzione blocca tutto
essere docenti onesti significa
accogliere i ragazzi
non barricarsi dietro la cattedra o
peggio ancora dietro piccoli posti di
potere
che spianano la strada ai soliti
preferiti essere musicisti e docenti
autentici significa cercare di
rinunciare un po alla vanità per non
barattare
la proiezione di quello che vorremmo
essere con quello che realmente siamo
questo è il mio contributo piccolo
nel piccolo mondo in cui vivo cioè
produrre musica che mi rappresenti
autentica e che soprattutto sia fedele a
me stesso e
formare delle persone che
indipendentemente dalle loro scelte
future musicali o o o non
genereranno crescita a loro volta in
questo contesto di bellezza di
condivisione di ascolto e di non
prevaricazione e questo contributo io ve
l'ho voluto portare quasta sera proprio
pratico i ragazzi che entreranno oggi
coronando il mio sogno cioè il sogno di
unire i due mondi di musicista e di
docente sono l'espressione della scuola
statale italiana
la scuola che insomma tutto sommato se
la cava bene anche senza troppe rotelle
o troppi algoritmi che dovrebbero
risolvere i problemi perché c'è il
personale scolastico fatto dai docenti
di ruolo dai docenti precari dai presidi
dagli anni insomma da chi lavora in
amministrazione e dal personale ata che
in realtà sa che la scuola e va vissuta
ogni giorno e ogni giorno è un'occasione
per divertirsi per per andare lì con
grande sorriso grande passione e fare il
proprio mestiere divertendosi
loro sono
mattia rizza
luca vadalà luca vadalà faccio questa
battuta da otto anni
ginevra bonaccorso
vittoria di grazia loro hanno fatto con
me le scuole medie ad indirizzo musicale
poi io mi sono stancato di loro sono
passato al liceo musicale loro stalker
izano mi sono venuti pure al liceo
musicale ora basta
ecco fortunatamente oggi sono
degli abilissimi studenti nei
conservatori italiani e voglio chiudere
questo talk questo questo incontro con
tato augurando buone feste
e con 2 con due cose che mi stanno a
cuore la prima è una
citazione
di una breve
poesia di danilo dolci che è un poeta un
attivista un
1 che ha lottato tantissimo per i
diritti umani un sociologo
che paragona l'insegnamento al sogno io
ho coniato un neologismo anche questo
sarà un delirio per la traduzione o
definito questa cosa il sogno più
l'insegnamento all'arte
dell'insegnamento che a me mi piace
tanto ed è questa ve la leggo
la leggo da qua non ho bisogno degli
occhialetti da 14 euro a 99 c'è pure chi
educa
senza nascondere l'assurdo che è nel
mondo aperto ad ogni sviluppo ma
cercando di essere franco all'altro come
asse
sognando gli altri come ora non sono
ciascuno questa la dedica poi cresce
solo se sognato danilo dolci
e mentre mentre raggiungo lo strumento
che ha cambiato la mia vita che è questo
qui ma soprattutto ha cambiato la vita
dei miei vicini di casa
voglio dirvi che oggi è il
il 18 dicembre e il 18 dicembre di un
anno fa un medico anestesista
gelese che lavorava al policlinico di
catania ci lasciava lui si chiamava
christian ilardi il dottore cristiano
ilardi e lui per me per chi lo ha
conosciuto è stato un esempio di grande
insomma di tutto quello che abbiamo
detto di generosità di onestà
autenticità e
e quant'altro
il suo lascito
è quello di vivere bene il tempo che ci
viene regalato e di vivere appieno ogni
istante della nostra vita tutto questo
fracasso e anche per lui
[Applauso]
[Musica]
un problema grazie